we heard the first details of this
shooting while people were in five
states including texas voting in primary
elections the biggest primary news comes
from georgia where republican governor
brian kemp beat his trump-backed
challenger former senator david perdue
it was one of several defeats for
candidates backed by the former
president but trump's choice in the
georgia senate race football legend
herschel walker easily won the gop
nomination
that sets the stage for a hotly
contested race in november against
democratic senator rafael warnock ed
o'keefe is in atlanta ed did anyone talk
about the texas shooting after the
election
well michelle good morning besides a few
brief prayers and mentions candidates
mostly moved on from the shooting in
texas focusing on their results last
night the biggest contest as you
mentioned were here in georgia and in
his acceptance speech last night the
georgia governor brian kemp focused on
his record on the economy and keeping
georgia open during the pandemic he made
no mention of former president donald
trump who campaigned hard against him
and instead focused on his democratic
opponents stacy abrams it'll be a
rematch for the two of them this fall
abram says she's tried telling georgians
four years ago that electing kemp was a
mistake and she'll do it again this year
meanwhile republican former football
star herschel walker as you said now
faces democratic senator rafael warnock
in a race that could eventually cost
tens of millions of dollars as it's one
of the few competitive races that could
determine who controls the senate next
year the georgia elections official who
most prominently stood up to the former
president by refusing to manipulate
election results his name secretary of
state brad raffensberger he fended off a
challenge from several different
opponents down in texas the political
dynasty of the bush family may have come
to an end at least for now state
attorney general ken paxton defeated
george p bush the nephew and grandson of
the former president bush paxton was one
of the few winners last night who
addressed the texas school shooting
publicly saying in an interview the
teachers should be armed as a solution
to school shootings keep an eye later
this week on a meeting of the national
rifle association in houston among those
scheduled to speak at the conference
former president trump
gail
former president trump senator cruz and
governor abbott will all be there i'm
told and thank you